[Music]
you know when i was a kid many years ago
it was a thought that the left who we
perhaps erroneously called liberals at
the time
mainly wanted to break down boundaries
and establish a free less rigid more
open society
now i didn't think that about the left
even when i was like eight years old i
knew better but lots of people did think
it in recent years however even the most
naive and oblivious among us have
finally begun to understand the truth
leftists on the whole are not only
uninterested in freedom and openness but
are in fact primarily focused on
establishing boundaries that's their
main thing this is the defining
characteristic
of the modern leftist he wants more
rules
more ordinances and mandates more
fencing to contain and control people
it's just that the boundaries he seeks
to set
are arbitrary and capricious and often
psychotically petty
and he himself is always of course
exempt from them
just the last few days have given us a
couple of examples of this sort of thing
we start here in modesto california a
quote straight pride march
uh quote devolved into violence as the
new york post puts it in their report
when counter protesters clashed with the
marchers outside of abortion clinic
now it's generally agreed by the media
and by the account of protesters who
showed up at the march and seemingly by
most people on social media
that a straight pride march is not only
absurd but also inherently bigoted
and yet the very same people who will
categorize a straight pride march in
that way
will also insist that gay pride marches
are noble and important
so here we see the arbitrary boundary
being put in place
gays can march you know and they should
be celebrated for doing so heterosexuals
who march are bigots and morons
that's the boundary
but it makes no sense
there is no intelligible reason
that anyone's ever given or could ever
give why it's acceptable to march and
express your pride in every sexual
orientation under the sun
except heterosexuality
just as there is no intelligible
coherent reason why it should be
considered good and healthy for every
race and ethnicity to express pride in
themselves and their heritage except
white people
the left has attempted to build this
fortress around the concept of pride and
declared that no white straight people
should ever be allowed inside yet they
can't really justify that
everyone everywhere
is allowed to be proud of who they are
the left says except white straight
people they're the only ones who can't
in fact for them
such pride is it's unthinkably brutally
racist and bigoted
and this is the rule they've established
and for whatever reason most people are
happy to follow it without asking any
questions about it
now in reality
i think it's ludicrous for anyone to
take pride in their sexual orientation
being attracted a certain way is not in
itself an achievement
now i take pride in my beautiful wife
and my children my family
none of which i would have if i wasn't
heterosexual but
it it would feel
rather reductive and silly to call my
pride in my family straight pride
actually rather than a straight pride
march i'd be in favor of a family march
how about that
perhaps we should have a a march
celebrating the family
celebrating the nuclear family that's
what the march should be
don't call it a straight pride march
called a family pride march
not a bad idea the more think about it
in any case the point is that however
silly a straight pride march might be it
cannot possibly be any sillier than a
gay pride march
and that i'm guessing is the primary
point that the people in the straight
pride march are trying to make you don't
get to make rules for us you don't get
to grant yourself special privileges it
doesn't work that way
if you get to march then so do we
that's the point it's perfectly valid
the left's boundaries that they set up
should be broken down just simply for
the sake of breaking them down
and this is especially true as the
boundaries become more bizarre and
constricting and trivial let me ask you
something what if there was someone out
there who kept a log of every single
thing you did every minute of the day i
think that would be pretty creepy if
that was the case well what if i told
you that's exactly what happens every
time you go online your internet
provider like at t or comcast is allowed
to store logs of every website you've
ever visited and they can legally sell
this data to anybody they want that's
why i always use expressvpn expressvpn
reroutes your internet connection
through their secure server so your
internet providers can't see or log what
you do online now many of you might be
wondering well if i'm routing all my
data through a vpn then doesn't that
mean that the vpn can see what i'm doing
and they can log my data instead very
astute well here's what i'll tell you
you're right to think that way many vpns
claim to have a no logs policy but
they've been caught logging customer
activity anyway expressvpn is the only
vpn i trust because they use trusted
server technology and you don't have to
take my word for it or express vpn's
word for it expressvpn is so confident
in their no logs claim they even had one
of the biggest assurance firms audit
their technology stop letting people
keep logs of what you do online visit
expressvpn.com
matt wall show right now and find out
how you can get three months free
there's a tick tock user who goes by the
handle a mushroom blackly
and she went viral over the last few
days with her reaction
to a drew barrymore video
where barrymore runs laughing through
the rain
now a mushroom blackly has decided that
uh it's racist for a white person to
frolic in the rain
so that's why she now i can think of
many reasons to oppose adults doing any
kind of frolicking at all but she's
making it racial and she's saying that
the problem is that if you do this then
you're racist against black people
though she's not really able to explain
why let's uh listen
you and i both know
that you are capable
of enjoying the rain
and frolicking freely without filming it
and then posting it to tick tock
now you've just co-signed
okay you just co-signed at least three
million eight point five by eleven front
and back
people who just go out of their way
to disrespect and
dismiss the boundaries that black
creators have set
and now you're one of those people
so
i guess my question would be
why
why why is it so important to all of you
to treat us like
we don't matter
now it's hard to know
exactly where to begin here uh she makes
clear that black tick tock creators have
set a boundary
which forbids white people from publicly
enjoying themselves in the rain
we may do so privately perhaps in our
own backyards where no one can see us
but we may not make a spectacle of this
enjoyment
and if we do
then we're not only racist but we're
sending a message that black people
don't matter
so you watch that video of drew
barrymore
laughing in the rain
what she's she's laughing about the fact
she she's she's like this is like an
evil laughter she's laughing about how
much he hates black people
apparently
yet it's not explained why this is
racist or how frolicking in the rain
could send a message like that or why
these boundaries were set were set or
perhaps more importantly why anyone
should give the slightest damn about the
boundaries she has set up for us
now fortunately she did post a follow-up
video with more information so maybe
we'll get a little bit more clarity here
why is it
an issue for me to stand firm in what i
believe
male black craters frolicked in the
grass female black creators started
frolicking in the rain
okay oh poor drew had a hard childhood
says the white woman to the black woman
in america i'm not picking nobody is
picking on her i pointed out the obvious
but
what y'all really are not catching
is
the
reactions like okay say that was a
complete and total stretch right
y'all still went out of your way to
demean me
put me down call me out my name
dismiss my opinion on my own tick tock
but defend drew in her hard childhood
because she's the only one who ever had
a hard childhood
we went out of our way to dismiss your
opinion and demean you because you're
stupid that's why
it's a perfectly logical response
but but it all makes sense now uh well
it doesn't make sense but at least now i
understand what sort of nonsense we're
dealing with
a mushroom blackly believes
that white people cannot engage in any
form of frolicking not just frolicking
in the rain but even frolicking in the
grasses out of bounds
because
black people on tick tock frolicked
before us apparently there are black
people on tick tock frolicking this is a
thing i guess
and but they invented it and having
invented it nobody with lighter skin is
allowed to engage in it therefore
so what drew barrymore has done here is
a form of frolic based plagiarism
this is the claim
and it is of course
mind-numbingly stupid
though i actually appreciate it in a
certain way because mushroom blackly has
inadvertently illustrated the absurdity
of the appropriation charge now this
might be the most absurd version of of
appropriation but it kind of shows it
it's symptomatic of of pretty much all
appropriation claims
because obviously
black people did not invent frolicking
they weren't the first ones to do it in
general nor to film it
and even if they did which they didn't
that still would not give a certain race
ownership over the practice of
frolicking frolicking is open to all
races i myself frolic through fields of
daffodils on a weekly basis and will
continue to do so it's how i get my
cardio
but this is how the appropriation claim
usually works a white person is accused
of stealing something that first of all
was absolutely not invented by the race
they're accused of stealing it from and
second of all cannot be stolen anyway
because it cannot be possessed in the
first place
but this is almost beside the point
the boundaries are not meant to be
logical or defensible or morally
coherent they exist simply to be abided
by
the left erects these fences and walls
and the rest of us are meant to just
live within them
as the boundaries get closer and closer
together and more and more things become
suddenly off limits and more and more
things that you enjoy doing and i enjoy
doing like frolicking
all of a sudden you're not allowed to do
anymore it's a game of power and control
and the only way to win the game
is to refuse to play it
so
march for straight pride if you want
frolic in the rain
you can even
frolic for straight pride
though that may send
mixed messages
do whatever you want
because the people who set these
arbitrary ridiculous boundaries are
today cancelled
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt walsh show if you did be sure
to subscribe to this youtube channel and
click the notification button to get
more content like this if you want to
watch or listen to the full show head to
dailywire.com and subscribe today you
can also listen to my podcast on spotify
apple podcast or wherever you get your
podcasts